last night we told you about a pretty
weird experience we had this week
on monday one of our producers in new
york overnighted a package to our
executive producer justin wells
and to me in los angeles we were there
preparing for an interview with a former
biden family business partner called
tony bobolinsky
somewhere along the way the contents of
that package disappeared inside it was a
flash drive that contained
primary documents pertaining to the
biden family we should tell you those
documents did not come from tony
babilinski and of course
we made a copy of those files before we
sent them because we're careful
we get a lot of documents from a lot of
different sources all the time but
that's especially true in election years
and before we put them on the air we
have to determine first whether they're
real these were real
whether they're newsworthy and whether
it's legal to show them
we wanted to assess what we had and
we're still assessing it but the point
is the package never arrived
proprietary reporting on the biden
family documents sent between
journalists by supposedly secure
overnight mail
disappeared and they vanished on the
same day we were conducting a heavily
publicized interview based in part on
documents from the biden family
so as you can imagine we wanted to know
what happened unfortunately we still
don't know what happened
this morning ups issued a press release
announcing they had found our flash
drive and then boasting about their
customer service quote
ups will always focus first on our
customers and will never stop working to
solve
issues which is fine ups is a reliable
company
they rarely lose anything we agree with
that that's why we use them in the first
place
and yet they lost our biden documents
how
ups won't tell us how we spent a lot of
the day talking to executives there they
claimed that the flash drive was found
on monday night by an hourly employee at
the ups building on 43rd street in
manhattan
they suggested it might have been
sitting on the floor there they couldn't
prove that because
remarkably in a room where millions of
high-value packages are handled
there are no security cameras that's
what they told us
ups says the employee who found our
flash drive simply dropped it on top of
a supervisor's desk
our documents sat there undiscovered for
more than 24 hours until we announced on
television that they were missing
that's their story obviously we had some
questions about it
but ups executives did not answer our
questions quote
there are no more details security is
returning it apologies again that we
were unable to deliver it next day at
the service level you requested
our exchanges went on like this for
hours and the main question we had never
changed
how did our flash drive get separated
from the package that we sent it in
that seemed like something worth knowing
the envelope was securely sealed we know
that two witnesses saw our producer seal
it and ups does not dispute that
was the package torn open accidentally
by a machine
that seems unlikely ups says that almost
never happens
so we're left with the obvious
explanation someone for some reason
opened our package and removed a flash
drive containing documents that were
damaging to the biden family
we'd love to know who would do that and
why it would be helpful to see the
envelope itself but ups says we can't
see it because
they threw it away so here we are we got
our flash drive back today and that's
great
but we'd really like are some answers
and speaking of answers it occurs
as reading this that we mentioned the
documents that we get from a lot of
people
and we've received an awful lot of
documents recently about hunter biden we
haven't aired
all of them in fact many we have not
aired the ones that are pertinent
to his business career abroad favors he
did
on behalf of foreign clients with the
help of his father that seems relevant
and it seems like news and we brought it
to you and we have we're not ashamed of
that
but there are a lot of documents about
hunter biden's personal life that we
haven't brought to you
and we're not going to and we should
tell you why one is the obvious answer
he's not running for president and so to
the extent those documents
pertain to his dead of course but hunter
biden
is a fallen man at this point and i
should also say that i knew hunter
biden fairly well we lived near each
other in washington for quite some time
i knew his wife was an absolutely
outstanding person a good person
i never thought hunter biden was a bad
person i thought he had demons but
in the time i knew him he kept them
mostly under control at some point he
lost control of those demons and the
world knows that now
he's now humiliated and alone it's
probably too strong to say we feel sorry
for hunter biden
but the point is pounding on a man
jumping on piling on
when he's already down is something that
we don't want to be involved in
so with that